hello and welcome to this video playing
yoop yoop yeah this is some funky flag
let's sound something exotic tokelau
yeah okay so let's see what the
strongest giving us I've played a line
again that I have recommended in my
repertoire my penguin repertoire this is
a bit more funky than what I usually
played against against this opening but
I think it's very ok and much more
interesting
yeah very weird em hit the night on d6
but black has some good play with this
early be five what what's position also
looks somewhat cramped maybe I had Nazi
forward ok I want to cancer of course
but 94 something that yeah ok now it's
definitely over this possibility but
something that definitely was
interesting ok I wonder how to do this
here if I should play Bishop e7 to
clarify the situation in the center or
just this maybe just this I might be
able to take on d5 ok so this is
basically not relevant anymore ok he has
covered f5 so neither fibers well let's
see i'm not sure about this if this is
all that bad I have rookie aid and d6
coming I mean he has no development
whatsoever
okay okay
Beastie six or what's the point distant
probably the night f3 and this is a this
is hard to tell what what's going on
here that might be excellent for for
either side yes
a d5 is the clean solution now takes it
you take it a couple of times and then
take on e6 yeah okay come on keep it
simple let's not do anything fancy
and that it's also it's also just good
to check nothing nothing to to add that
just better for black and probably
winning with the best play okay so i can
check him and then enter on the second
rank let's check should work so i can i
can enter even with this rook check so
which is a check where is the mate
and
didn't see a maid but I think this is
enough yeah now i can check em or queen
e 6 on between e 6f five ruger five yes
check okay
still no mate you're kidding I don't see
it I'm such an idiot okay I can take you
it should have been checked made a while
ago it see what I didn't see one
ridiculous okay I'm threatening on g4
now I know threatening rook f3 which
also should be made this one Queen I
can't find one that's really really
embarrassing time morning don't find a
mate datasets embarrassing it's probably
maybe like ten mates or something and he
must also think like oh my god i'm
playing a complete [ __ ] that this game
is so continuing check I don't believe
it really
chats really really hard to believe that
I didn't find a mate down check king of
three we're still made some of this rook
isn't isn't really all that great this
one check my god so here what about this
kind of kind of played this ending maybe
check I have to play AB [ __ ] ending
yeah I'm sorry bad my language this is
this is crazy I don't believe all this
already how can I not win this this this
by checkmate that's really absolutely
amazing at least like is that win the
game but this is this is an unbelievable
display of incompetent so so ripped it
to Jack and Queenie to work occasionally
rookie three is checkmate I mean this is
just check check check why didn't I do
that I was chatting I was thinking every
check match every check should win but
this looks very very check nice yeah
it's just it just it is a major can take
care this is this is chase also I made
check check make sure you check mate a
nice one check so I mean it'sit's chat
or still minus a million but I didn't
find a mate Queen age six now is leading
to a mate check and this is not this is
not winning this is still a maid I'm
such a macho of course first is chick
and then take their check check check
yeah and then I had to play this this
pretending ok I mean with the coming
outside passwords anybody if anybody
black wins but I know I wasn't totally
sure I'm really really winning here yeah
I'm probably winning I was g five draws
ok yeah this is wrong he has to of
course go into the corner oh my god oh
my god I think I need a break thanks for
watching